what's up guys all marvel's heroes are
coming to the same place on the Disney
Channel
Marvel Studios Avengers infinity war
here's a special look there was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people so when they needed us we could
fight the battles that they never could
[Music]
you know what it's like to move
evacuate the city
and get this vanish sheet let's go
[Music]
are you guys
this gun contains scenes and language
that may be inappropriate for younger
viewers hey everybody so Disney dropped
a new promo for infinity war with Tom
Hall on there obviously Disney young
audience so spider-man's gonna be the
guy to market it to them but we got to
talk about the infinity gems after Black
Panther so in case some of you haven't
seen Black Panther yet I'll just save
that part for the end of the video we'll
just go down the roster there's also a
new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video but what I'll do is I'll
talk about the gems in the order that
the analyst is going to collect them but
based on recent promo art that we've
seen we know he grabs the green Time gem
in the yellow mind gem last so starting
with the blue tesseract last seen during
Thor Ragnarok
[Music]
then when Loki goes back at the end of
the film he sort of looks at it it's
implied that he grabs it while they're
escaping Asgard then obviously we have
that post-credit scene where they're
talking and the giant ship shows up
Kevin Feige recently confirmed that
that's called sanctuary - meaning
sanctuary as in where Thanos is from so
that is Thanos coming to collect that
gem I feel like everything's gonna work
out fine
[Music]
Feige did explain that loki would at
least seem like an ally of Thanos so it
seems like after this moment happens
here Thanos kills a couple people Loki
offers him the gem without any
resistance but somehow they get Hulk
back to earth because he crashes through
the sanctum he Thor winds up floating
through the vacuum of space somewhere
but then we also see that os-- with the
gauntlet in full frame plopping the
purple power gem into it he probably
destroys most of the Nova Corps or
destroys part of it and then once he
grabs it then he blows the rest of the
planet up we don't know exactly where
these ruins are where he's fighting them
but this could be the ruins of the Nova
Corps then he grabs the red reality gem
from the collector this is the clip of
that
stop reality stone No
I told you I sold it I imagine it's like
breathing for you suicide so you do
understand
not even you would surrender something
so precious I didn't know what it was
and you are the fool that I took you for
and so last chance Charlotte where's the
stone today he pays for the deaths of my
wife and daughter
skipping over the soul gem real quick
I'll talk about that in a second but I
do think that's the next one that he
goes after but the green time gem in the
yellow mind gem are two battles that we
see during the trailer we see them
attack dr. Strange's sanctum sanctorum
it's not like ebony maw and the Black
Order are going after the Avengers
they're going after the time gem the
avengers just happened to be there but
that fine along with Corvus glaive and
Proxima midnight going after vision like
you can see Corvus glaive staff in the
middle of his forehead trying to take
the gem out those both seem like they
come relatively early in the film and
are unsuccessful because we saw that
clip of them sort of wheeling in vision
to the New Avengers facility where
everybody thought that it was Captain
Marvel since been confirmed that this is
Scarlet Witch even though Captain Marvel
is featured during infinity war she's
not been in any of the trailer footage
that we've seen so far sliding into
Black Panther territory this is where
you know it's not important that you've
seen black panther but if you don't want
to know anything about that movie then
I'll say spoiler warning I'll wait just
a second so we found out there is no
soul gem no infinity gem in black
panther meaning that the soul gem is
gonna have to come from somewhere else
the reason why what Conda is important
is because it seems like the outriders
are going to come to grab vision because
there was this whole backstory that they
did with the pre lewd comic about how
Sheree was going to fix the winter
soldiers mind meeting that she had
really advanced AI that was more
advanced they said in the comic book
than the AI that was used to create
Ultron why is that important because
that same AI was used to create vision
so if she understands that that means
that she understands how vision works
and one of the best quotes that she had
from the film and I feel like it's a
little wink at what's happening during
infinity war when she says great another
broken white boy for me to fix what does
vision look like during the infinity war
trailer another white boy even though
he's an Android
but it's just another thing for her to
fix when the black order comes to get
the mind gem they're gonna have to find
a way to separate him from it without
completely destroying him but because
the whole idea of Avengers 3 in Avengers
4 is that Thanos assembles the affinity
gauntlet he's going to get that mind gem
eventually but if you're a big comic
book reader you may have noticed that
they've changed the colors of the gems
from the comic now the big one that goes
the middle is going to be the mind gem
so that's why I think that that's gonna
be the final one that he collects so
that means that he gets the green time
gem before that at some point but just
remember that as he collects more gems
the powers of the gems will stack on
each other so like once he gets the
space gem he can just teleport wherever
he wants to once he gets the power gem
it will amplify the effects of that he
could teleport his entire space fleet
into Earth's orbit it'd be a really easy
way to get the outriders there for that
invasion of Wakanda but what about the
soul gem there were all kinds of
theories that it might secretly be
contained inside the great mountain it
might be responsible for some of its
special properties but ryan coogler
actually explained why they didn't do
soul gem this is a little clip of him
talking about it I love that finish doll
as much as any comic book fan you know
it's just what kind of kinda hazards are
already hazards Dean which is vibranium
um for us died without was special
enough so sort of throwing something
like another special thing it didn't so
they just felt like vibranium by itself
was special enough in the comics
vibranium doesn't have any connection to
the infinity gems there are two
completely different ideas everybody had
been hoping after guardians of the
galaxy too that it might be tied to Adam
warlock but then James Gunn came out and
said no you know we're probably not
gonna see that character again until
Guardians three meaning that he would
sit out both Avengers 3 and Avengers 4
for a long time there was that Heimdall
theory because he can pinpoint anyone
anywhere in the galaxy but the problem
is is the whole idea at the end of Thor
the dark world is that they don't keep
infinity gems in close proximity to each
other they gave the power gem to the
collector because they didn't want to
have the power gem in the space gem
right next to each other in Heimdall is
there too
so they would have three infinity gems
if that were the case so I think the
fact that they only wanted one on Asgard
sort of pours water on the Heimdall
theory but it doesn't disprove it
there's still no official confirmation
one way or the other so what might end
up happening is is they'll introduce the
soul gem through some other storyline
now it could have something to do with
Thor's new weapon in the dwarves we
haven't really seen the dwarves we've
only seen the space Forge we've seen
Thor on that planet where they're
fighting Thanos but not in any of the
recent promos
the thing about Captain Marvel is as I
actually don't think that she's going to
show up
the very end of the film and this is
they're gonna introduce the character
but I don't know if it's gonna be
spider-man Civil War style or if is
gonna be a post-credits scene where she
just shows up at the end like oh wow you
just got your asses handed to you but
there's actually no confirmation that
Thanos gets all six of the gems by the
end of infinity war they might actually
leave that for the beginning of Avengers
4 because this behind the scenes shot
was actually taken after they had rapped
on Avengers 4 so let me know in the
comments where do you think that soul
gem is we're down to Heimdall which is
you know slim chance still possible the
Dwarven storyline with Thor we haven't
seen anything from them so that's
actually pretty slim chance or possibly
Captain Marvel brings it herself Kevin
Feige has been talking a little bit
about some of the other films that are
coming up like ant-man and the wasp as
well as Captain Marvel let me know if
you have any special video requests for
that stuff but you can click here for my
black panther post credits scene video
and you can click here for that infinity
war promo where they show up the
gauntlet with all the gems in it thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]